[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كره القدم وجدت اصلا في الثقافات القديمه
جدا يعني في الثقافه الفرعونيه في الثقافه
في الثقافه الصينيه وما الى ذلك
بمفهومها البسيط لكن مع التقدم والتطور
يعني توارث هذه اللعبه اصبحت جزء من
الثقافه
[موسيقى]
تحول لعبه كره القدم الى ان تصبح من مجرد
هوايه جسديه الى ثقافه او جزء من ثقافه
المجتمع اصبح لها هذا الدور لو قعدنا ما
هي العوامل اللي جعلت من هذه الثقافه مهمه
لدى مثلا من جميع المجتمعات في العالم
خصوصا في هذا الوقت حنلاقي ان هي مرتبطه
بالتنشئه الاجتماعيه مرتبط بالطفوله
مرتبطه بذلك بذاكره المكان والزمان بمعنى
انه دائما نحن الى ايام الطفوله كيف احنا
نلعب كره القدم مع اصدقاءنا في المدرسه
وما الى ذلك حتى اطفالنا من اول ما ينشا
الذكور نجد اهتمام بكره القدم
[موسيقى]
مثلا عمليات الاجتماعيه مثل التنافس وهي
جزء من الطبيعه البشريه نجد ايضا غير
التنافس
التكييف وهذي كلها اشياء تؤثر على
ايضا هي مرتبطه باحلامها وتوقعاتنا
الفوز والشعارات اللي احنا بنستخدمها
اغاني الاهازيج اللي احنا نستخدمها في
التعبير عن الحب كره القدم ايضا هي تحولت
مع الزمان الى مشروع تنموي انساني
[موسيقى]